hi-yah everybody ready gonna be all
settled in here we go
name-o markiplier you cleared probably
normal saving map seed map see
oh it's randomly generated okay here we
go
Iraq intro sequence it's loading ooh
okay hello oh what the hell what the
hell
hi buddy Oh
[Music]
what what happened okay ah-ha
yes next time oh my why I even know I
don't even know
okay object classes why what the hell is
a class d personnel punch him in the
dick I don't think he has a dick what
the hell okay
as soon as it I'm just running no no no
you FS right up
[Music]
oh boy oh boy
what's help I can't see a bloody thing
oh okay wow what is that
Oh what the hell
ah kick it up what no no not again no oh
damn it did I
I failed oh yeah I think blinking like
crazy
okay.what da
[Music]
coffee coffee yes it hurts my eyeballs
huh tonight odd dammit
yeah it's a blinking meter oh boy
why can't get out what let me out let me
out
[Applause]
yeah it's a blinking meter when it runs
out you have to close your eyes okay um
damnit I think damnit I think I might
have fallen or - I think I might have
actually failed here that's stupid I
don't think there's any way out of here
doesn't seem like it huh okay I think I
just have to like yeah I picked up
something oh I see a gas mask ah okay
that's better
all right I see let's see what's the
same ah special containment procedures
item scp-173 is to be kept in a locked
container at all times when personnel
must enters scp-173 Eskin Taner no fewer
than three may enter at any time and the
door is to be relocked behind them at
all times two persons must maintain
direct eye contact with scp-173 until
all personnel have vacated and relock
the container it is constructed from
concrete and rebar with traces of Krylon
brand spray-paint scp-173 is animate and
extremely hostile the object cannot move
while within a direct line of sight -
site must not be broken at any time with
scp-173 personnel assigned to enter
container are instructed to alert one
another before blinking object is
reported to attack by snapping the neck
at the base of the skull or by
strangulation okay okay I got batteries
what do I do with batteries
damnit
how'd I get out huh
ah I don't know I think I think I messed
up and I have to go back and redo it so
that I get through the door in time but
that's kind of weird that it would be
like that okay I'm just gonna go back
out try this again
huh uh uh uh I'm gonna go back I don't
want to go back I don't want to go back
I don't want to go back I don't want to
go back I don't wanna I don't wanna okay
I'm staying out here huh I'll stay nope
back home nope on that one
[Music]
all right okay and that it knows them
nose up how are them okay
oh I see it Roma yeah okay okay okay go
go go go quickly run I'm barely bad it
escaped oh no no no more okay Oh
the door control system okay burner
extra uber double murder okay how did I
not get in with the room with the last
time I can't be anything this is
different Oh golly
Oh God okay what is this what's this
gimme okay I don't I don't know I don't
care okay okay okay I don't care okay I
don't care I don't care yeah random maps
right a mess huh
uh-huh okay okay seems okay good [ __ ]
all I need the gas mask oh okay
how can I save I just just a button I
don't know how to save okay doesn't look
like it's in there whoa what was that
okay looks clear okay there go go
through going through going through made
it
aah
[Music]
not so scary I'm too tough for this okay
totally making my way through aah
more gas
okay okay okay hello
I'm okay I'm okay
what kind of containment facility is
this a bad one
oh shut up guy oh this isn't even fair
okay all right okay hey I need to how do
you save oh oh okay oh okay oh don't ask
girls both don't ask it's okay
it's bad someone said that five okay I 5
eggs pally bro
at five to save okay
[Music]
I don't know if that's actually saving I
don't see a confirm well I don't I don't
get a gas match this time I can't carry
more items I have no items
Oh what in the hell is that what's in
that corner it's a yeah
it's in there it's in there how do I get
past it it's in there it's in there is
that it it didn't look like it
Oh what is that Oh what is that what is
it music no that didn't say I did not
save it didn't save it didn't save oh
it's like slamming my head into a wall
you have to watch it at all times okay
[Music]
I'm okay I'm tough I'm tough
I can do huh what's up buddy huh
blanks man a lot of people suggested
this game that's a good thing I suppose
this is condoned misery Oh give me an ax
oh no no no no no
what don't make me do it don't make me
do it again
don't make me good don't know okay
anytime there's music I need to either
turn around I just turn around to look
at it
no no no not this time
opponents how is it you have so many
battery okay keep an eye on you the
entire day just look at you I just have
to look at you I have to look at you I
feel look at you put the gas mask on put
to get back yes why can't I hold all the
batteries we're here what are the
batteries oh I'm getting it yeah I'm
getting it hey buddy
[Music]
what is up with your face what is going
on with your face buddy I don't even
know and here we go
adventure begins oh oh no no no stop
spitting on me Alon oh boy
Oh Blake stop like get around get around
itself like dumpling dumpling dumpling
dumpling don't blink don't close the
door close the door yeah close the door
Oh can't give me through doors okay oh
oh
oh there are other types of monsters
besides that guy I don't know I don't
know oh I don't care I don't care actor
baron I don't even care you try to play
this game personnel please enjoy the
contain looking at me yep okay
not again not again get those going my
way the batteries for whatever reason a
means
hey is it in there
oh it's in there that's in there put on
my gas mask okay and wait to blink
getting the corner there where is it
where is it where is it I saw it I think
it's in the corner there okay okay amen
Oh press space to blink oh okay
he was on your left either oh man Oh God
okay trying again trying again class and
even personnel please enter the
containment unit oh okay
[Music]
okay this way and then go through here
batteries watched by me he's not there
close the door okay okay the space to
blink okay Christopher f1 is safe okay
ah that's much better
oh okay okay close the door
okay don't go that way don't go that way
okay at least I won't have to start over
every time now okay oh great my friend
per second just like tank for some
reason
okay whatever he's through that door
why was my frame per second so low it's
the only one I look in that direction
maybe that's trying to tell me don't go
that way bro
what the hell frames first second Oh
seriously my fps is like dropping like a
rock
oh is it pitch black in there I cannot
see anything there we go there we go
ah there's more monsters annually Blake
why does my FPS so low Oh what's going
on here
there's Lee calm down FPS calm down
frames seriously frames seriously frames
what was that what was that what was
that oh that what what was that I got 12
FPS like a boss supercomputer is not
doing well what is that that's a
different one I need two key card to
operate this door Oh what the hell is it
my gas mask that's doing it no oh no
cannot see cannot see get out
can I see going to ten frames a second
[Music]
ten frames a second for some reason and
friends all the whole game is exploding
everything's your trippy
oh my god close it up again good idea
blink okay go through No
[Music]
ah that's in the walls oops on the walls
okay Oh what is going on with this game
oh where where where I heard music right
oh and the whole game is like exploding
all around me I'm gonna have to reboot
the game after this death next death oh
where are you where are you where are
you where are you don't pull me book I
forgot to blink
[Applause]
shut up take your time out dr. Baron no
I won't
oh okay whoo whoo okay try to stay out
of the smoke okay
whoo all right oh man
okay let's hoping that the memory access
violation thank you thank you breaking
computer whoo aah
uh I'll be right back
fix this I gotta like I think the whole
yeah whole game crashed I got started up
again oh boy oh boy okay oh man oh here
we go Oh xsplit xsplit
Oh oh man I'm recording local copies of
this so I should have everything yeah
yeah I did okay frame rates much better
okay there was nothing past here it's
just that the thing was in that room
there it is hello buddy oh boy
okay gas masks on okay where ya buddy
where ya
like go where is it where is it I don't
see it I was right there it's right
there go don't know I didn't make it in
time I didn't make it into I don't make
it make it make it gender and making it
done and make it in time I didn't make
it in time I didn't make it can I run
sideways so I need to do okay I can run
while going sideways
okay okay okay where'd he go where'd he
go I can't read
Oh where do you I don't see him I don't
see him but I know he's in there I know
he's in there
okay here we go here we go here we go
here we go where are you Mary where are
you there yeah okay keep in line aside
yes okay close the damn door huh hey
Steve okay moving on over 900 close
close close take off this link save
again save one more time oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh I'm so I'm so
fond he's right there he's right there
he's good day pwned
I'm so screwed
hi hi
maybe if I get him in this room and then
get around him
Oh blink okay no please don't leave me
alone okay I'm gonna blink
where did I save where am i where am i
where am i black lots of black blackness
everywhere darkness surrounding my soul
where'd it going where we going
this isn't good I don't see nothing I'm
I'm pwned but my load failed my save
failed and I got a hat again
oh I'm not gonna sleep all the night oh
sorry my phone oh dammit my save failed
I saw myself flying through them I'm
okay
[Music]
I need to take a break
I either break doesn't man die oh oh
[Music]
SCP 87b I don't know what that is
Oh more shots for October and okay I'll
keep going I'll keep going here we go
we're going we're going we're going if
it's to get you guys wasted I'll keep
going oh oh oh okay okay oh let's see
here okay let me just save to start off
saved huh you're taking shots of patron
what kind of college student are you
any more attempts to close it so um
please maintain a direct eye contact
with scp-173 enemy
I don't believe your octave Aryan you're
really rich you still want all of us
with less of you for being rich close
the door
alright save again cuz I'm [ __ ] like
that oh no I don't get a gas mask
what the hell I don't have any hi I
don't have any gas masks all right all
my eyeballs
okay I just got wait here until my eyes
clear up no there was only one room in
that in that in that one okay here we go
here we go it's my time I thought okay
[Music]
dark are you never oh I don't have a gas
mask please don't be in there okay it
looks clear it looks clear it looks
clear yeah just whenever I die take a
drink I think it's clear I think it's
clear I think it's clear I think it's
good oh my god oh my god okay okay it
was good a hole where the hell am I
gonna get a gas mask I don't know I
don't know I don't know safe I don't
know
I don't know there was stuff down here
before was this okay safe any SCP object
classed as safe is usually a little more
than a curiosity to the research teams
blah blah blah Euclid Euclid is Gerren
applied to objects whose properties are
not currently understood
unlike safe they are not reliable there
are no reliable containment procedures
they do not obey laws of nature's and
physics okay
Keter the strictest objects class
Keter can be handled by Class D
personnel except in special
circumstances natural inimical to life
and pose great difficulties in keeping
them controlled neutralize any object
that has since been destroyed or is in
no ways odd extra dimensional
decommissioned ok disavowed by the
foundation ok ok say blink sibling yes
was this security clearance levels ok
zero one not permitted any contact with
SCP level one standard its level to
approve gentleman with a three security
staff level four command level personnel
level five highest ranking senior staff
ok ok ok
[Music]
I've never seen this before I like a
good Smirnoff nice and an amaretto sour
those are delicious Oh Oh me no likey
me no likey you know like oh no back
here I don't need to be back here it's
too quiet what's up here it's doesn't
look good
need a keycard hey hey what the live
same Oh everything's good but that was
gonna that was gonna oh I didn't die
ah no no oh no
huh what what huh hi lady
oh yeah no oh oh yeah what the hell
no well how do I get out
how do we get out how do we get up
huh why it's the whole world turning
it's like when you spin around too fast
and the whole world just starts turning
oh nothing can get out I'm not dead I
got kind of a heck of a oh boy oh boy ok
I'm back here
hi okay bye
I see you buddy pal buddy pal friend oh
I'm in a different place I'll save again
ah I don't know I don't know why is it
dark why is it dark truly dark God
okay
okay on my back to the beginning
what the hell what the hell
it's so quiet and and what what yeah
what yeah what L say huh
ah
what is that is it here what's happening
what's happening what's happening card
car Java battery get the card huh
what is it I don't know drop drop these
stupid papers huh save let's do this is
the mistake I'm sorry buddy
I'm sorry give me damn oh oh okay okay
said okay this is one of the security
doors okay okay okay
heck
save again hey I can't see nothing huh I
like dark inter it's dark it's dark it's
dark it's so dark okay spriting save you
guys
what has happened did I fall no I hear
footsteps what's going on
rose dudes pally wellies um I think I
may have to load the game again yeah
yeah yes but I would happen I think I
went to a wall ah damn it
all that progress I think is gone Oh
what the hell is that
the first save is from my first game but
I think it was after I died oh oh it's
my repeated attempts to petition the
termination of his scp-173 have met with
oh five being steadfast I'm hereby
instead suggesting we extend security
measures I think it will be prudent to
redesign one of the can empty
containment cells to include a set of
three doors arranged like a double
airlock I also suggest that we revise
the cleaning procedure to only carry it
out with trained personnel d-class just
can't be trusted with this please let me
know about your decision as soon as
possible I decided to make crude drawing
to illustrate my idea
Thank You pally bro I like my voice too
I can do a Swedish accent as well okay
oh my hands are shaking Oh oh Jesus
I have no Jesus Oh what time is it 1008
oh oh wow oh I can't do any more I can't
do any more that's it for tonight
oh man that's it for tonight sorry guys
Oh huh okay yeah SCP os8 7b oh yeah Oh
see oh I'll look it up I'll get the next
one it's like a sequel to this game but
thanks so much hope you enjoyed this mr.
treat oh god my heart I have a soul I
have a local copy of it saved all try to
chop it up into the best bits and heck
that'll be a whole new reaction
compilation I suppose oh okay thanks so
much for watching guys hope you enjoyed
that it'll be it'll also be up on twitch
TV the whole thing will be up on twitch
TV but I'll uh I'll cut it up as best I
can and put it on YouTube whenever I get
a chance so whoa okay thank you all so
much for watching
woo all right I gotta go look at
pictures of like puppies and kittens and
stuff cuz that was downright that was
horrible that was horrible how's it
horrible oh it's this game Oh first
before I go this game it's available for
free if you just look up SCP containment
breach
on Google you'll find it it's it's a
wordpress paid but it's got a download
right there it's version point to I
bleach should I go should I click on
that link you just you just fooling me
digging digging with me haha okay haha
alright not going there haha okay
alright not going there not go in there
alright thank you guys so much for
watching as always I appreciate it so
much though huh thanks again and I will
see you
you know in the next video bye bye